This situation is reminiscent of
the network of specialized suppliers to
a manufacturing company.
One makes seats, but
not radiators, while another
makes dashboards, but not tires.
But somehow it all comes together
seamlessly to produce a great car,
those industries long ago recognized the
need for automation to help coordinate
their supplier network starting with
the automobile industry in the 1980s.
Until very recently, and this really
only started to change as a result of
the federal programs we'll
discuss in this lesson.
The healthcare industry
tried to operate its complex
care network using paper records and
fax machines.
Name an example of a specific,
non-healthcare,
non-automotive corporate success story
in using information technology to
manage a complex logistics network.